Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Enfant, c’était à celui qui cassait
le plus de joysticks avec mon grand frère.
C’était lui le vrai geek de la famille,
il faut quand même le dire.
Je ne me rappelle pas mon père
avec une manette dans les mains.
C’était un lecteur,
un lecteur de science-fiction :
Herbert, Asimov, C. Clarke.
Et quand il nous offrait une machine pong
ou une console vidéo puck,
ce qu’il nous donnait, c’était
de la science-fiction, c’était bien ça.
Et pour lui comme pour nous, on recevait
quelque chose comme un morceau du futur.
Adolescent, le jeu vidéo est encore là
dans ma vie,
mais c’est à mon tour
de tomber dans la lecture.
Je dévore tout : je dévore Freud,
Duras, Tolkien, Stephen King,
tout ce qui bouge, tout ce qui tombe.
Le jeu vidéo est là
comme un divertissement,
c’est le médium de ma génération.
Étudiant en philosophie, le jeu vidéo
prend de plus en plus d’espace.
D’ailleurs, il prend de plus en plus
d’espace dans les ordinateurs
parce qu’il a de plus en plus
de choses à raconter,
des histoires de plus en plus amples
et des mondes de plus en plus complexes.
Ça se complique quand
je commence à travailler.
Je m’y perds complètement.
J’y passe mes nuits.
Il y a notamment un jeu qui
m’a tenu beaucoup de nuits.
Un jeu américain qui s’appelle Half-Life.
Vous interprétez un chercheur,
pas un ingénieur EDF,
un chercheur, mais pas
bien musclé non plus.
Pas du tout un Superman.
Et évidemment, comme dans tout jeu vidéo,
il y a une invasion extra-terrestre.
Vous devinez la suite :
il va falloir sauver le monde.
Sauf que dans le jeu, à un moment,
l’armée arrive, des soldats débarquent
et là, c’est la cavalerie.
C’est un jeu américain : on est
censé quand même être sauvé.
Et pas du tout.
Les soldats vous tirent dessus.
En quelque sorte,
c’est une géniale trahison.
Ordre a été donné de ne laisser aucun
témoin sur la base de recherche.
Et donc, le jeu nous trahit.
C'est une belle trahison.
C’est la première fois que je vois ça.
C'est la première fois qu'un jeu est sans
doute le reflet de la condition humaine.
Ce qui m’amène ce soir devant vous,
c’est cette conviction née ce soir-là :
derrière Half-Life,
il y avait un je ne sais quoi.
Ce je ne sais quoi,
cette chose invisible qui était là,
qui se cachait,
qui était pourtant bien là,
c’est que le jeu vidéo, c’est de l’art.
Un matin de 1879 -
il n’y avait pas de Half-Life -
un matin de 1879, la petite
Maria Sanz de Sautuola
visite la grotte d’Altamira, dans le nord
de l’Espagne, avec son père.
La grotte d'Altamira, c'est l'un des
joyaux européens de l'art pariétal.
Et elle s’arrête devant un dessin
et elle crie : «Toros, toros !»
Ce n’est pas du tout un taureau,
c’est un bison, ce n’est pas très grave,
et le père, Marcelino Sanz de Sautuola,
qui est juriste, archéologue amateur,
daigne lever le nez sur le dessin.
Il y a un déclic dans sa tête.
Un déclic parce qu’un an auparavant,
à l’exposition universelle de Paris,
il a vu gravé sur
une pierre un tel dessin.
Et à Paris, ce dessin était présenté
comme de l'art pariétal.
24 ans.
Il va falloir 24 années
de durs combats scientifiques
pour que Marcelino Sanz de Sautuola
fasse reconnaître la grotte d’Altamira
comme un joyau de l’art
pariétal en Europe.
Ce qui me fait penser à cette anecdote
autour de la gare d’Orsay.
Je ne sais pas si vous savez comment
on appelait la gare d’Orsay
parmi les guides parisiens
dans les années 70.
On appelait ça l'immeuble
le plus laid de Paris.
C'est aujourd'hui l'un des cinq musées
les plus visités au monde.
Eh bien, pour moi, le jeu vidéo -
Dans un mois j’ai 50 ans
et le jeu vidéo m’apparaît encore
comme l’immeuble le plus laid
du secteur culturel.
Pourquoi ?
En 2016, le ministère de la Culture pose
la question à des centaines de Français :
« Pour vous, c’est quoi la culture ? »
La culture, ce n’est pas que
de l’art, mais l’art, c’est de la culture.
Vous n’avez pas été interrogés,
moi non plus,
mais en numéro un, on trouve évidemment
les musées et les monuments nationaux.
Il y a aucune surprise ici.
En avant-dernière position,
on trouve le jeu vidéo.
On est juste devant la télé-réalité.
(Rires)
Marrez-vous, marrez-vous, mais on est
juste derrière la pêche et la chasse.
(Rires)
C’est ça qui fait le plus mal, en fait...
la pêche et la chasse.
C’est moche, j’ai mis longtemps
à m’en remettre,
2016, vous voyez, j’en parle encore.
Le jeu vidéo n’est pas de l’art,
en tout cas, si l’on en croit Ian
Lawrence Cesling, c’est un historien,
l’art nous ressemble.
Nous décidons de finalement
de ce qu'est l'art.
Mais il rajoute que
nous sommes plus que du silex.
Nous sommes plus qu’un ordinateur.
Or je pense que le jeu vidéo,
c’est plus qu’un ordinateur.
C'est plus que les 100 milliards de
dollars de business annuel sur la planète.
C’est beaucoup plus que ça.
Le jeu vidéo a en lui un je ne sais quoi,
il a en lui un «toros».
Marcelino Sanz de Sautuola visite
la grotte d’Altamira depuis 1876.
Trois ans, trois ans avant le cri
de la petite Maria.
Pour vous expliquer comment est
la grotte d’Altamira,
c’est une grotte de 300
mètres de profondeur.
Il y a effectivement beaucoup
de dessins, de gravures,
mais on peut passer à côté.
Mais à l’intérieur de ces 300 mètres,
il y a une cavité de 18 mètres sur 9
où il y a au moins
250 gravures et dessins.
C’est plus qu’un nez au milieu du visage.
Marcelino ne pouvait pas
ne pas voir ces dessins.
Et il va visiter la grotte
pendant ces trois ans.
Vous dire en 2021 que le jeu vidéo
est de l’art, c’est un peu crier «toros »
dans un appart de 100 mètres carrés
avec 250 jeux vidéo géniaux.
Des artistes géniaux d’ailleurs, il y en a
dans le jeu vidéo, il y en a plein.
Il y a des artistes de l’image,
du son, des mécaniques de jeu
des artistes de la technologie,
des architectes
pour fabriquer tous ces mondes
absolument incroyables.
Les musées du monde entier
accueillent le jeu vidéo.
Le Grand Palais à Paris, la Cité du design
de Saint-Étienne, le VA de Londres,
le MoMA de New York accueille le Pacman
dans sa collection permanente,
dans sa collection permanente.
Il y a quelques mois, il y a une copie
immaculée, jamais ouverte,
de Super Mario Bros
qui a été vendue à plus d’un million
et demi de dollars aux enchères.
Un million et demi de dollars
pour une boîte de jeu,
en espérant qu’elle contienne le jeu,
(Rires)
sinon ce serait inquiétant.
La technologie NFT également
promet de créer des jeux uniques,
commercialisables, non reproductibles.
La technologie NFT permet,
en tout cas promet,
d’être un titre de propriété
pour un bien numérique.
Ça pourrait être, dans ce cas-ci,
un jeu vidéo
et du coup, il deviendrait
commercialisable comme une œuvre unique.
Mais, un marché de la collection,
même un marché de l’art,
ça ne nous dit pas ce que nous, ici,
nous ressentons de l’art.
La sensation de l’art quand
on le ressent, c’est quoi ?
Je pense qu’il faut se tourner,
pour avoir ces réponses,
non pas vers les philosophes,
mais plutôt vers les artistes,
et aller peut-être du côté
de chez Marcel Proust.
Proust est mort à 51 ans.
Il passe les quinze dernières
années de sa vie
à écrire «La recherche du temps perdu»,
quasiment alité.
Je pense que ça vaut le coup d’écouter
ce qu’un tel homme a à nous dire, à nous,
habitants du 21e siècle, sur son art -
son art, c’était la littérature.
Il nous dit par l’art seulement,
nous pouvons sortir hors de nous.
Grâce à l’art, au lieu de vivre
un seul monde ici avec vous,
je peux en vivre une multitude,
une foultitude.
Voilà ce qu’est l’art.
Donc, ce soir, laissez-moi vous
emmener dans ces mondes vidéoludiques
que vous ne verrez plus jamais
dans la réalité.
D’abord, l’Amérique
de la fin du 19e siècle.
Une Amérique prise entre nature sauvage
et l’urbanisation
et l’industrialisation galopantes.
C’est un peu la fin des cow-boys
et la fin des bandes de hors-la-loi.
Ça, c’est un jeu.
Ça s’appelle Red Dead Redemption 2,
une simulation de western
qui peut être très amusante : vous pouvez
décider de braquer des banques.
Vous ne craignez rien.
C’est comme tuer les extra-terrestres,
c’est plutôt sympa.
Mais vous pouvez aussi pêcher, chasser
ou simplement vous asseoir et regarder
la nature sauvage vivre.
Jamais vous ne serez aussi près d'un monde
qui a à jamais disparu, jamais.
Mais un monde n’a pas besoin d’exister
pour nous émerveiller, finalement,
pour nous transporter.
Si Red Dead Redemption 2
est un jeu pharaonique :
800 personnes sur 8 années,
c’est le temps de production nécessaire,
il a fallu une personne sur une année -
Delphine Fourneau, c’est une Française -
Le jeu s’appelle Sacramento.
Ça raconte l’histoire d’une femme,
d’un homme, qui s’endort dans un train
et qui se réveille
dans ce monde poétique en aquarelle,
en forme de peinture à l’eau.
Et on se met à voguer, à vaquer,
à découvrir, à explorer cet univers
et puis finalement à se réveiller
dans le train
et n’avoir qu’une seule envie : retourner
dans le monde de Sacramento.
Mais un monde, ça peut être
aussi une émotion.
Les choses intérieures.
Et pourquoi pas le deuil ?
Aux alentours des années 2010,
Ryan Green, un Américain,
apprend que son fils de 1 an, Joel,
est atteint d’un cancer incurable.
Il n'a que quelques semaines à vivre.
Avec sa femme Amy,
il décide de réaliser un blog,
d’y mettre les poèmes, les prières, les
dessins pour raconter le combat de Joël.
En 2013, Joël a quatre ans.
Il résiste toujours à la maladie.
Et Ryan décide, il est informaticien,
d’en faire un jeu vidéo.
Là aussi, pour raconter cette vie
de tous les jours et cette vie de combat.
Joël disparaîtra juste avant
son sixième anniversaire.
Le jeu est sorti.
Il s’appelle «The Dragon Cancer».
Dragon, c’est le nom donné
par Joel à sa maladie.
Le jeu vidéo peut-il nous aider,
nous les vivants, à dire au revoir
à celles et ceux qui partent ?
Vous allez me dire que c’est une question
bien incongrue quand même.
On est quand même loin de Fortnite,
de Super Mario Kart,
de Minecraft, qui a été cité.
Le jeu vidéo ne peut-il pas
rester à sa place finalement,
être un simple divertissement pour nous ?
Ne peut-il pas juste rester là où il est ?
Je vous le disais, la grotte d’Altamira
était connue des habitants de la région,
des villages alentour,
qui n’y voyaient absolument aucune valeur,
en tout cas, n’y prêtaient pas beaucoup
attention jusqu’à l’année 1868.
En 1868, Modesto Pérez, un chasseur -
encore la chasse - un chasseur
entre dans la grotte d’Altamira,
voit les peintures,
il ne crie pas «toros»,
ce n’est pas tout à fait ce qu’il fait,
mais il comprend intuitivement que ça a
de la valeur, que ça peut se vendre.
Il va écrire au roi d’Espagne
pour lui vendre la grotte d’Altamira,
pour lui vendre sa pseudo-découverte.
L’art n’est jamais très loin,
ou trop loin, de l’argent.
Enfin, le Pacman -
tout le monde connaît le Pacman,
je ne ferai pas un dessin -
le Pacman, est-ce de l’art ?
C’est finalement ça, la question.
Un jeu qui nous paraît aussi divertissant,
aussi vieillot, aussi ancien,
peut-il être de l’art ?
Il y a peut-être une réponse
une nouvelle fois chez les artistes.
Il y a un documentaire français
du début des années 80,
qui s’appelle « Sans soleil »,
réalisé par Chris Marker.
Et Chris Marker nous dit que le Pacman
qu’il découvre au Japon
au début des années 80 -
le jeu n’est pas encore arrivé en France,
là-bas, c’est un phénomène -
il nous dit que le Pacman est le reflet
exact de notre condition humaine.
En quoi un morceau de pizza glouton
est-il le reflet de nos vies ?
Regardons-le un peu ce glouton
dans son labyrinthe.
Il mange pas mal.
Un peu comme nous, parfois il cherche
à manger, parfois il mange.
Parfois, il y a des bons repas.
Il y a beaucoup de moments de peur :
on ne connaît pas tous les tournants.
Il y a des moments de joie,
des moments de gloire,
quand on échappe aux fantômes
ou quand on les mange.
Mais in fine,
à la fin, la routine est toujours
la même : le Pacman meurt.
Le Pacman, c’est de l’art.
Le jeu vidéo, c’est de l’art, mais c’est
de l’art à l’état de je ne sais quoi,
à l’état de «toros».
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)